how often do you see fights like that in
Hawaii it was every week pakalola park
or meters in Salt Lake that's where
everyone would smoke yeah everybody
there too
my cousin comes I was like yo some guy
wants to fight you and I'm like what did
I do I'm over here everyone's like you
gotta go so you don't even know I was
just walking towards Long's Drugs I look
behind me there's like 10 of my homies
go get them and I'm like oh you know I'm
actually hyped right now I see my
opponent and he has his family why does
he want to fight just for my cousin
who's saying my cousin can beat your ass
a bit that's the word so go up to him
damn this food's tall I'm gonna get my
ass beat my pose up and then you hear
auntie in the corner you [__] us I try
to smoke
in my head I'm like Auntie break it off
the auntie's friend comes out like you
[__] you wouldn't mind you smoke time
and he comes in the middle of it he's
like you know what you look stupid and I
was like yeah
[Laughter]
not scaring you so nothing happened
nothing happened thank God for the
answer Andy's and uncles pulls up you
gotta listen